and her diamondbacks starting pitcher
today the right-hander jake ferry of
five appearances with the d-backs and
this is his third start
two and two on garrett hampson
swinging a miss good start for jake
foreign
on the ground to first pavon smith is
there for recovers two up and two down
and a ground ball to short shoot down
the inning ahmed flips two van meter at
second and that will end the ending so a
6-4 put out the rockies taking care of
the first snow run snow gets chichi
gonzalez making his 13th start of the
year that's a new career high for
chichi he has four appearances out of
the bullpen the last couple have been
very good gonzalez with the o2 pitch and
it swung on foul tipped into the glove
of dom nunez for a strikeout a couple of
breaking balls and then the heater to
get the punch out
and this is bounced in the area of the
double play there's one and not in touch
he swings at a high fast ball and pops
it up on the left side of the infield
ryan mcmahon at third has it and chichi
posts a zero here's job nunez with two
out mcmahon still stuck at first
this ball is pretty well hit to left
and it's really well hit and it short
hops the wall which is a good thing and
mcmahon's going to get a green light
he's going to come home and score on a
double by nunez so good for dom nunez
just his seventh road hit of the year
and he hit one in that corner we saw one
in that corner from mcmahon last night
unfortunately it bounced out that
would have prevented a run here but
mcmahon scored from first because it
stayed in play well that was good too
because the rockies need to get on the
board first it hits up right underneath
that yellow padding 02 pitch with two
outs
straight three car right down the middle
and the side retired but not before the
rockies break on top one run on two inch
of man left here's the pitcher chi-chi
gonzalez with a couple of board
and this is slash to right that's a fair
ball
come on down yo to daza and the rockies
have a two to nothing lead dom nunez
goes first to third through one fastball
too many chi-chi didn't even realize
that was fair initially hey first rbi of
the year for gigi inside out swings
oh yeah
very nice
spicer down the line
first rbi this year number three of
chichi's career
behind the count two balls no strikes
into third escobar to second
and then finally out of the beginning
rockies add one more they lead it to
nothing and juarez gets first crack he
popped out to win the first his first
downhill and he walked him outside ball
four could have been so now the battery
is joshua that's a bullet down the line
gaza over to cut it off
reddick has to stop it first and
juardo's in it third good start here to
the d-backs for threading two for two
chance for stewart fairchild his first
major league start fairchild the ground
ball back up the middle storey's got it
gets the out at sega gets the out at
first double play
but a run comes in to score story took
it away from fairchild and turned it
into a six four three double play one
two and a swinging strikeout on a 92
mile an hour fastball up and out of the
zone so chichi walks escobar he ends up
coming around two to one colorado first
man off the bench for torrey lavello the
smasher who has done almost nothing but
pinch hit since he's been back up here
this is driven deep to center field
andrew young gets off the wall
the smasher
a one out double
well that was barreled up
it's up to josh van meter now
van meter launches one down the line can
it stay fair
hey it's gone josh van vader makes it
3-2 diamondback
yeah would it stay fair and wasn't high
enough to get over the fence a line
drive home run on a 91 mile an hour
fastball inner third of the plate
absolutely smoked that one to right
field
so charlie blackman pinch hitting here
with crone at second and nunez at first
0-1
and this ball on the ground toward the
middle of the diamond and he gets passed
for a moment the middle midfielder and
coming home he's crowned with the tying
run and nugez to third charlie blackman
comes through
good read by crone good read by stu cole
the third base coach
and also by dom to be able to get to
third because this ball
i thought this was ticketed for center
field but then it goes off the glove
and this kicks away and no one knows
where it is and the rockies take the
lead
dom nunez cruises home
weems saw it but he couldn't communicate
the holiday exactly where it was
and on a wild pitch the rockies have a
four to three lead back in front
swinging a miss hampton strikes out for
the third time today that'll end the
ending but not before mortgage damage
done the rockies get two runs in the
ending on only one hit that's riley
smith and he's going to be on the bump
facing tapia story and rogers
hard ground ball and that's fair down
the line double territory for rymel
and
it hit one of the security folks either
way
it's a double so a good start in the
seventh for tapia here's story
maybe 14. did he catch this
deep left and off the base of the wall
it kicks a long way from peralta topia
scores easily and trevor story with a
double he makes it five to three oh so
close
42nd rbi for story first and second
still no one out here's mcmahon
and this ball is in the air to shallow
center and it's gonna drop story got a
great read he's coming home and rogers
had to wait he got the second
it's a run-scoring single for mcmahon
make it 6-3 colorado 24th pitch oh man
[Applause]
we've got cj right in the helmet
he's nodding to dan molino that he's
okay
hopefully he got all the hard plastics
toward the back of the net
i'm glad too he's wearing the extra
you know facial protection yes i mean he
walked down there and now
doogie's advising that he'd come out
they're gonna go with john gray so
they'll save a bench player here
will be the hitter
and this ball is lifted to plenty deep
enough left field to get a run in and
it's not caught by peralta
two runs are going to score as mcmahon
is coming home depending on how they
scored it could very well be a double a
third in the inning for daza bases full
of diamondbacks and nobody out
popped it up
infield fly in effect and that's the
first down
and this is in the air to left toppy is
gonna get behind it the runner at third
is varshall and varshall down by five
runs did not uh
look to tads
and this is right at fuentes and what a
job by schatzin faces loaded no one out
and he works out of it unscathed second
at bat for fuentes and a live drive
through the right side dom nunez around
third coming home
and
the throw is gonna go to second and no
tag there
so an rbi single for fuentes the rockies
have a 9-3 lead yensi almante on for the
rockies for the ninth 31st appearance
well there's that vintage slider we saw
last year that'll end the ball game as
he strikes out rojas a one two three
nine the pen does a nice job today and a
victory for chi-chi gonzalez his third
of the year